[Music]
if you have seen jurassic world dominion
then the most obvious question many of
you will have is why is rexy weaker than
the giganotosaurus and if she backed
down from the first confrontation in the
valley
then why did she challenge the giga
again in the end of the movie and most
importantly why did she almost lose
here are five reasons why the
giganotosaurus was more powerful than
her
number one size and weight so as we can
see from the movie and the prologue the
giganotosaurus was indeed larger than
the t-rex at least in the movie universe
in real life they are more or less the
same size so in dominion we can clearly
see that the giga was as large or maybe
even larger than the spinosaurus and the
indominus rex putting him well around 50
feet long around 6 feet longer than rexy
he also looks to be much bulkier and
heavier at around 9 tons putting him 2
tons above rexy which is around 7 to 8
tons in weight with just that itself the
giga has the size advantage in sheer
brute strength
number two armored skin
the biosin apex dinosaur also has
crocodilian-like skin which was kind of
weird as it was a dinosaur and not
related at all to alligators or
crocodiles but the spikes on the neck
and back as well as the
osteodome-covered skin acted as sort of
an armor against challengers and other
enemies it was able to shrug off even
the deadly bite of the t-rex which is
touted to have the most powerful bite
force of any land carnivore ever so in a
one-on-one fight the toughness of the
skin adds to the endurance of the animal
and it protects it from the shock of the
teeth piercing into the meat of its body
this definitely is another big advantage
for the giganotosaurus
number three longer forearms
this here is a game changer in any
battle it's not as important and as
valuable as mma fights where the fighter
with longer arms have a clear reach
advantage
because of punches but in the diner vs
dino fight they still play an important
part nonetheless if you remember the
spinosaurus vs t-rex fight of jurassic
park 3 where the fight was initially
skewed in favor of the t-rex but was
suddenly turned in favor of the spiner
when the latter used its longer arms to
grab the neck and with that helped its
jaw to snap it well even though the giga
didn't have arms as long as the spino it
was still miles longer than the
thickly tickly arms of the t-rex rexy
had arms as long as a man's arms but
let's face it it's a huge dinosaur the
other one had 6-7 feet long arms which
will obviously help it to scratch hold
push and pull in a fight
number 4 it's more well fed
this overlooked fact is one thing that
is one of the most important factors of
the outcome of the battle between these
two behemoths the giga was stated to be
the apex predator of the valley and even
though the t-rex was also an apex
predator it was visibly smaller and
shorter than the giga so whenever there
is a confrontation for food and space
the smaller wrecks would just back away
than risk to fight and
be injured unless backed into a corner
or trapped together in a same confined
space
therefore in many of these encounters
the gigger would come out on top and
then half a fees leaving the t-rex
without food and less energy so whenever
they meet the gigger's battery
will be fully charged while rexie's
would be low and in need of a recharge
and lastly number five the height
advantage
lastly this is the defining factor in a
fight between these two carnivorous
theropod dinosaurs why well these apex
carnivores use their jaws as the main
weapons and both animals have extremely
powerful bite forces but their main
angle of attack is to bite down on their
prey biting up isn't as easy as a thing
to do when you look at the vertebrae
being attached to the upper part of the
skull so it kind of hurts when you look
up so bending the head down is more easy
than looking up even though they could
do it
the bite won't be as powerful as biting
down on something and this is where the
giga clearly outshines the t-rex
as you can see in both the battles the
giga easily manages to sing its team
into the shorter rexy while the other
one struggles to land a bite on the
bigger enemy
and that my friends are the 5 reasons
why the giganotosaurus was more powerful
than rexy
the iconic t-rex of the jurassic
franchise
anyway with that we come to the end of
this video so do hit that like button
for support smash that bell icon for
regular updates subscribe as well
and also till the next one
take care fam